[Music]
nikki is in wichita kansas hi nikki
what's up
hi dave um
not a lot how are you today better than
i deserve how can we help
good um i'm calling because
my husband and i we
own two houses well right now we're
we have a mortgage on one and
one
is supposed to be our rental property we
haven't been able to rent it yet
um but it's the house that we lived in
when we got married four years ago
and um he's always had a dream to
rent this property and he
he just really wants to rent it
and
i have a lot of conflict so we've been
trying to follow your steps since we got
married since before we got married
and he's the one who introduced me to
you
and
um
so we we paid off all of our debt after
we got married and we are still
debt-free praise god
um
but
um i know that i've listened on your
show before and we've
been partially through financial peace
university and we've gotten some advice
from some of our church friends and
um renting this house
doesn't seem like the right thing to do
right now
um
and i really don't know what to do it's
caused a lot of conflict it's like the
main conflict in our marriage
and
i'm just calling you to see what you
would advise me to do
okay um
well uh
i
i hear him whining in the background he
was always my dream and you're a dream
killer that's what i'm hearing
because the way you were shamed into
your into your sentence structure
uh i heard shame coming out i know it's
how he's always just dreaming i don't
want to kill his dream which means he's
been telling you that you're a dream
killer
and let me just tell you when you kill
somebody's nightmare you're not a dream
killer
you're a nightmare killer
and you know if somebody's doing
something stupid and you tell them not
to do it you're not a dream killer
that's an act of love
and so your disagreement is based in
love here it's not based in the fact
that um little boy can't get what he
wants um so let's not start there at all
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
dignify that with an answer but uh
but what what let's just back up a
minute i think the two of you need to
sit down with a marriage counselor and
pan back
because basically he signed you up for a
seri a way of handling money that was
proven
that would
be the shortest distance to wealth and
generosity
and then once he signed you up for that
he changed
horses
and decided anyway my dream i went a
rental house with dad
and um so he's the one that changed the
deal here so somebody has to kind of
help you guys navigate through
the mediation of
him changing the direction because you
didn't change anything
he said hey let's do this dave ramsey
stuff and then he goes well i don't
really want to do it anymore
am i missing something
no i don't think so okay
and you sound awfully tired fatigued and
beat down by a stupid rental house
discussion
it's just a house
yeah
okay
i i will mention also that it's been in
his family
so
he has had his family let him know
that
they would rather him not sell it
well then they ought to buy it and
yeah
i agree
you know and it's
okay there's so many guilt trips in the
i mean you guys you guys are good travel
agent for guilt trips around there
him his family it's like a modus
operandi so you the two of you need to
decide what is best for the two of you
if it includes keeping this house and
paying it off very very quickly that's
okay
if it includes keeping this house and
staying deeply in debt because my family
shamed me into it and my husband shamed
me into it this is toxic as crud
this house is paid off um we completely
own this house we don't owe any money no
the one you're talking about renting
right
right you got debt on the other house
yes the house that we live in we bought
in 2020. oh and you but you but you
borrowed money on it because you didn't
sell the other one
right yeah so
so effectively you borrowed money to
keep the other one
yeah yeah what will the other one sell
for
um the rental yes
uh
well it's appraised at 45 000. 45 000.
yeah
well this is a fine piece of property
it's really small it's like a little one
bedroom one bathroom
um house
most people call me with car payments
bigger than this
and y'all are arguing about a dump of a
house
oh lord what's the rent on that i can't
imagine it's
it's a piece of trash
there's no question listen 20 years from
now are you going to be glad you own
this as an investment no
it's not going to get better it already
sucks
no i don't want this piece of real
estate
no no no no no no no no no if you want
to keep it as a is there land with it
no there's not there's nothing wrong on
the value
no it's a tiny it's
it's a tiny house on a big lot yeah
and it's very very old and very dumpy
yeah yeah
it's 45 000
girl this tells us everything we need to
know
okay so here's the deal i i don't care
but here here's the thing
the question you all have to ask
yourself as a couple
other people outside of your marriage do
not get a vote in this including me you
call me for my advice i'll give you my
advice but i don't even get a vote okay
you guys got to decide what you're going
to do and the question you do is the two
of you as a husband and wife need a pan
back and say 10 years from now 20 years
from now which of these decisions are we
going to be glad we did
i can promise you having owned over 2000
pieces of real estate in my life that
dealing with the tenant you're going to
deal with in a 45 000 house for the next
20 years is not going to add value to
your life
this is going to be a total pain in the
butt
and all for nothing financially the only
possible reason to consider keeping this
house is it's been in the family
and uh it's a 45 000 keepsake but even
then it's it's listen this is this is
one of those things he needs to let go
off
and so yeah you need to you need to sit
down the marriage counselor because
the pain in your voice has nothing to do
with this property it has to do with his
family injecting themselves into your
all's life it has to do with your
husband changing horses in the middle of
the dead gum stream and saying well you
know i'm yeah
but yeah take the 45 000 pay it down on
your mortgage and then start working to
get your mortgage off that's what dave
and sharon ramsey would do even if the
little house had been in her family or
my family and even if our little
families didn't like it we would still
go
check it out if you want to keep it it's
only 45 grand run yourself down to the
credit union write me a check i'll hand
you the deed
yeah and i think the marriage counseling
is the key here
this thing has become way bigger than it
needs to be it's just not worth it it's
not causing a ton of financial stress
other than the upkeep so i think there's
two sides to this i think dave you're
absolutely right but i also don't think
it needs to cause this much stress for
her either it's not like it's burdening
them it's sounding exhausted it does it
seems like this thing has gotten huge
and it's a little teeny tiny house that
quite frankly they don't owe anything on
i would do the same thing and i'd take
the 45 now like today i'd take it yeah
and put it on the house
i'd take
35 well get rid of the problem it's it's
not a blessing it's a curse yeah yeah
and so it's i i is she it's gonna be a
long yeah
there's a reason you can't rent it hello
so yeah i i think there's the the
fatigue is not about the house it's not
about the finances about your husband
changing
horses in the middle
of the stream saying we were going to do
this now i decided i don't want to
and it's about all this interference and
argument over
really nothing
it's not worth